Ed Sheeran opens up about struggling
with an eating disorder the singer
getting candid about battling bulimia in
a new interview with Rolling Stone
magazine revealing he's a binge eater
who found himself gorging and then it
would come up again Ed says he's
self-conscious to begin with and being
in an industry where he's compared to
other pop stars doesn't help I was in
the One Direction wave and I'm like well
why don't I have a six-pack
and I was like oh because you love
kebabs and drink beer
Ed adds that he's worked with stars like
Shawn Mendes and Justin Bieber
[Music]
who Ed says have fantastic figures I was
always like well why am I so fat this is
just the latest Revelation from the
Grammy winner you guys said do you want
to make a documentary and I went yeah
and it should be me in the studio and
we'll play the gig that's not what the
documentary is
on Monday I dropped the first trailer
for his Disney plus documentary the sum
of it all out May 3rd offering fans a
rare glimpse into his private life
including his marriage to long time love
Cherry Seaboard everything in my life
sort of got so much better when Sherry
got into it I got married and I'm a dad
who has two daughters earlier this month
Ed announced his new
tracked will drop May 5th it was
inspired by a series of events that he
says changed his life mental health and
the way he views music and art first
Cherry found out she had a tumor while
pregnant with no route to treatment
until after the birth then he lost a
close friend unexpectedly and then
suddenly my best friend Jamal dies
[Music]
I was spiraling through fear depression
and anxiety I lost it just took over my
life every time something massive
happened I tend to write a song about it
every song reminds me you're gone
[Music]
I've never seen him cry on stage Ed
explains that as an artist he didn't
feel like he could release an album that
didn't accurately represent where he is
at this point in life so this record is
purely that he says it's opening the
trap door to his soul if you strip it
all back and just have me as a musician
as a and a songwriter that's that's the
moment that you look for not not
everything else back in February Ed
hinted at all that when he addressed his
recent absence from social media I've
had some turbulent things been happening
in my personal life so I just didn't
really feel like being online and
pretending to be something I'm not when
I wasn't feeling like at
the time he was doing better and
promised to bring some good content back
to our Instagrams
things are looking up and I'm back
online
so um
yeah no
weird it's gonna start being posted here
I made this video like 50 times I'm not
making another one
foreign